welcome to chess history World Chess
Championship we're going to talk about
the 1966 cycle between your two favorite
players
Spassky and Petrosian again I won't
pronounce their names correctly proving
that we're in America okay now some
people possibly Bobby Fischer claimed
the Soviets were cheating that when they
had matches and tournaments and such
that it wasn't fair and they should
change the system so that you know the
right players won not people who were
colluding okay this may or may not have
been true however those were the best
players so if the best players Roisin
the best players still got to the finals
a lot of the Olympics in chess in the 50
60s and 70s the the Soviets had a lot of
world champions on those teams sometimes
everybody was a world champion it's
tough team okay and there's been stories
which probably aren't true that they
didn't want Bob's vidicon that seemed he
was world champion cuz he wasn't strong
enough okay and then they put on board
one instead and he won the gold medal
all right now the world championship in
66 started with the intra zonal in 64
you may notice Fischer did not play okay
and in a 23 round tournament there was a
four-way tie for first amazing between
Smith Slav Larson Spassky and tall only
one of those people has been to my
wedding only one you know who was close
Spassky taller Smith Slav anyone know
also close Smith Slav he was at my
wedding in 1989 which in fact my
anniversary was a few days ago thanks
for asking
27 years ago on January 11th and speech
Slav is also of those players the only
ones I've played and I played him twice
I played Smith off in a simultaneous
exhibition which I'm sure he never
membered in 1984 in the Soviet Union and
plight of a 1988 boys bank just to be a
great tournament in England and I beat
him in the same oil where I was
completely lost and I drew him in the
slow tournament okay and I never played
the other three players okay although I
do teach Matt Larsen that's sort of
close okay the Americans didn't do very
well
we had Benko Evans and Reshevsky
and they finished so far down you could
never even see anyway after that they
had candidates matches in 65 and the
winner of these candidates matches with
Spassky fact Wikipedia has all the
matches right here that's very nice of
it okay so bob bennett could have played
in the candidates matches but he retired
so instead Geller took his place and
Geller actually won his match against me
saw five and a half two and a half
that's a good replacement that's pretty
good
and Spassky be care as in Spassky be
Galler Spassky beat tall and so in 66 he
was playing Petrosian for a petrosian's
world championship when he be bah Vinick
in 63 and Spassky was the favorite and
but he did not win factum they attended
twelve and a half 11 and a half okay so
Spassky had to play you know these guys
had to play 23 rounds and there's all
them play match after match after match
and then still lose 12 and half 11 and a
half
it's tough becoming the world champion
not easy again Carlson I'll tell you
that and yeah these are pretty good guys
although if cough got in so okay we
won't talk about that all right and this
match was very close as you can see
never more than a two point swing in any
case and after 19 games the match was
tied actually let's basket to win the
match okay now luckily in the rematch
and 69 which I'm sure someone will go
over later already has Spassky became
the world champion and the rest is
history
then the terrible movie pawn sacrifice
came out and then we get to have to live
with that nonsense all right now
Petrosian Spassky this has a very famous
end game when
- endgame I don't mean an endgame I mean
the end of the game the end of the game
is a very famous trick which my son
Spencer would approve of because he's
played this trick before and given
lectures on it and at the end he's like
just like Petrosian played because this
made this sacrifice famous okay so this
game was a king's indian Spassky likes
to play actively and Petrosian likes to
play solid and so it was very
reminiscent of the tall Botvinnik match
both of them because tall would play the
King's Indian
Bhavana could play solid and it was sort
of a which idea was better wild and
crazy' or solid and it depends who's in
form in the first match tall one and the
second match Botvinnik really be tall
badly and if you remember the Karpov
could smart off matches the first match
Karpov was up five games to zero with 24
draws okay and then after those 29 games
because far I've got the better of him
the rest of their careers usually but
okay he had to get chess lessons on how
to play good positional chess
okay so here we have a king's india by
transposition the g3 variation and this
is what Bhavan it played with white also
he liked to play the g3 variation now
tall played several different ways but
the way with ninety six which becomes
the panel variation named after your
favorite Grandmaster the the panel
variation panel his first name like No
well this is jeopardy what's that mr.
piano also known as Oscar piano okay he
was down with Opie at the time not OPP
high a six and blacks idea is to play
rook b8 and b5 or possibly e5 and before
that happens white plays d5 nowadays
grandmasters I like to play d5 because
it's too good they like to play solid
and passive so d5 isn't played very much
nowadays d5 attacking the knight the
Knight attacks the C pawn and white
defends the C pawn but if white defends
the C pawn with b3 you could see he
could get in trouble here on the
diagonal that could be very dangerous
even for example now
xD five as possible so players with
white usually play Knight d2 here and in
fact if you're in this room right now or
if you're at home you probably realize
that when I play Doug Eckert one of our
local club members and he's on the board
of the Chess Club usually I win when I
say usually what do I mean - any always
so since I moved to st. Louis over six
years ago I've won every game in blitz
tournaments rapid tournaments slow
tournaments and a bughouse doesn't
matter
well maybe not bug house podcast he
probably beat me anyway those games were
all revenge for this position I had this
position against Doug Eckert in 1984 ok
Orwell was pleased
ok you I'll give you guys a minute to
look up who horrible was Oh R wel L
George ah now they're like I interesting
ok and we had this position c5 was
played ok and the idea behind c5 is b4
doesn't win the night because you just
take the pawn ok and blacks going to
play on the Queen side because his
bishop is here his Knight is here b5 is
coming Rick ba and sometimes black opens
the center with e6 this ship f5 could
come attacking the rook on b1 which
happens a lot and that's the panel
variation and this was very popular
between 1950 and 1990 and since 1990
most grandmasters aren't playing the g3
line anymore
and the ones who do usually don't play
d5 so we don't see this very often
anymore but ok 1966 this was all the
latest you know theory okay so Queen c2
which defends the knight on c3 and you
might be thinking that Knights already
defended and yeah so I wants to play b3
defending his pawn this should be - the
Queen defends e4 and we can get an
advance here and the rooks will be
connected look we choose a normal move
and then e 5 was played by Spassky sort
of an unusual move I would like to
commentator of this game I would think
rugby eight and then B five makes more
sense
okay so e five and now it says B three
question mark some of the annotations of
this game are not right I'm assuming the
game was annotated in 1966 and
occasionally when the annotator give a
move a question mark and I put it on my
engine it said it was the best move so
yeah Petrosian and Spassky were pretty
good so when you give them question
marks between those guys there should be
a very important tactical reason like
the line they play doesn't work and this
line does but when they're playing
positional moves like b3 and it gives a
question mark I don't believe that
because if the computer said it was bad
I wouldn't believe it
it was tactical then I would believe it
okay so 9g for blacks playing very
aggressively and I like the move Knight
g4 because it proves my theory never
play f3 f3 terrible okay then the knight
goes to e3 doesn't even need backup okay
people at home won't get that but all
right so white played efore f5 this is
why Spassky played 94 he wants to play
f5 and then I can go to h6 if it has to
eat xf 5 following another one of my
theories always play he takes f5 again
and that Larsen I had a fun time talking
about that and the last tournament he
went to there were two games that went
f5 he takes f5 and he takes f5 was
correct okay and then G takes f 5 9 to
d1 which the commentators say Bishop b2
is better I don't have a tough time
believing that now of course we want to
kick the night out but we don't want to
move all our pieces all our pawns on the
Kings side because then white gets weak
in position like if f3 then 93 is good
so this is why Petrosian played Knight
to d1 that controls the e3 square so now
we could play f3 and kick the knight out
if we want to be 5 Spassky plays
reactively and in my opinion this was
the best game of the match game 10 game
7 was also quite good again the
Petrosian one I didn't want to show the
game Spassky won Spassky one fewer games
that would be tougher and Spassky lost
the match
so maybe the 69 minute I'll show a game
he won ok so be 5 so spassky's playing
everywhere ok now I had a lesson today
with Matt Larsen and a head of lesson
yesterday with Matt Larsen ok that's why
he's 23 35 and you're not and I said
Matt every game you move all any of your
pawns and then like the next few games
we looked at he would all eat of his
pawns
so I predicted he would do it and that's
what Spassky is doing in this position
so if I was Spassky his coach I'd be
like dude what are you doing moving all
of your pawns
now moving all of your pawns is fun ok
you move all your pawns then you do
what's called creating weaknesses your
pawns can't move backwards so all the
squares behind your pawns are no longer
defended which is what Petrosian
punishes his opponent this game danny
Machuca is like I beg to differ move all
your pawns yay ok
he's like active aggressive okay so why
played f3 which they gave a question
mark to and I was like yay f3 question
mark those are my kind of annotations
however the engine today says f3 is the
best move and obviously this is why
Petrosian played Knight to d1 he wants
to kick out the night but he stopping 93
okay and he plays efore and supposedly
this is why f3 is bad for tactical
reasons game and ie for the bishop is
attacking the rook and black really
wants the night to go to e5 that's a
nice square maybe d3 maybe take the pawn
on c4 for free since there's 5 guys
attacking it and he doesn't want to go
back to f6 and then he's blocking all of
his bishop is block as rook as nice and
I can't go anywhere so easy for very
aggressive okay
the rook is attacked on a1 so Bishop to
b2 he takes f3
this should takes f3 bishop takes
Queen takes Knight e5 the Knights great
on e5 the bishop retreats to e2
defending the c4 pawn and finally F for
which they give exclamation mark mmm
computers today yeah that moves okay
another way of playing which is also
suggested was Rick a7 so the rook can
come over here and help out can I
actually like to do that maneuver when I
play black and openings with c5 and e5
the 7th ring gets sort of open so
sometimes your book can come out their
way
getting your rook to the King stood on
the 1st rank not so easy this rank is a
little more easy to get to okay but some
ascii was in a hurry
he doesn't want white to get his pieces
the good squares and block everything
then this knight smell good and these
pawns are isolated and weak instead he
wants to attack because white has lots
of pieces not too close to his King
so he's like if my Bishop can get here
and my rook can get here my queen and
get here I have enough attacking pieces
if I don't do anything and just play
regular chess why is my knight on a 5
why are my pawns isolated so in the long
run whites can have a nice positional
advantage but in the short run you might
get mated so got to play for me f4 ok
now some of the annotations are not
necessarily correct here y could take
with a Recor the pawn my engine likes
with the rook the commentator says rook
takes is terrible but okay rook takes is
okay but I took with the pawn this is
fine and now very interesting maneuver
he played Bishop h3 which is a bad move
the commentators are correct Shroff
would not be happy the correct move is
the shocking what's the most shocking
move
there you go that's the that's the
recommended move rook takes f4 and the
idea is if you take the rock then Queen
g5 check wins the rook back and whites
King doesn't have a lot of pieces in
front of it okay and the computer
experts or the people back then
suggested 93 so the knight can defend
the King the Knights of defending
important squares and very importantly
the rooks are connected so maybe my king
can hide on each one and I can still
have some good rooks and to me in the
long run it's going to be very good for
white that blacks light is on 85 okay
and black obviously has the knight on e5
as his trump but okay
seems like this piece yeah all right but
rook takes F 4 was the correct to move
and probably white is slightly better
instead Bishop h3 which is the most
complicated move and here the annotators
are sort of mean okay they're like this
shove h3 question mark and not white has
a great position that is correct however
playing the right move for white that's
not easy maybe for a super Grandmaster
but for the people at home and the
people here this move is not obvious
okay normally when the guy plays Bishop
h3 attacking your rook you move your
rook away especially if you're my
student
because I told Mook away save your rook
okay but here we can't let black get an
initiative and keep attacking okay if in
fact white does move his rook then rook
takes F 4 is even better than it was
before
because we have a bishop on h3 for free
so instead Petrosian played a brilliant
move that he's very famous for Petrosian
is famous for what kind of sacrifices
what kind well actually
Petrosian made two or three very famous
Queen sacrifices like in this game but
he's famous for exchange sacrifices
usually he was sacrificing the exchange
just like make sure the game was a drawn
the guy couldn't attack this was a
little bit of the opposite and obviously
you
don't want your died on g1 the whole
game because then morphe would get mad
at you for having this rook on a1 so he
played Knights III and that's computer
recommended today also Knight c3 is the
best move and well the problem with
blacks position if he takes the exchange
is he doesn't have any white squares and
he gets punished really quickly and this
happens in a lot of Kings Indians except
usually especially when I'm white
White's playing 95-96 and black is
taking that Knight and black no longer
has the white squared bishop in this
case we're winning in exchange but we
still don't have any white squares and
also the white King which Spassky was
trying to attack is actually safer than
the black King which will get attacked
we have a queen on the diagonal we have
this open line here and our Bishop can
come to e6 if black doesn't take the
exchange it's not clear what he'll do
because his knight is attacked so he
played Bishop h3 takes the exchange
unfortunately you got really crushed on
the white squares and Petrosian not only
is winning for that reason as I said
earlier in the lecture the knight on a5
is really bad I think that the knight
was anywhere on the Kings side black
would be better but both sides are
playing for a King side attack which
happens when there's an open G file both
sides want to attack on the G file but
here white basically has an extra piece
bishop f1 following my rule always
played Bishop f1 the the commentators
said rook takes f4 question mark my
engine says Rick takes f4 is best so
okay they didn't have engines back then
they had to like do analysis on their
own yeah okay and they gave some crazy
variation rook takes check rook g4x clam
and everybody's pinned and hanging and
their analysis according to my engine
was not the best okay and that's funny
because it was a tactical sequence and
after the game is over and they analyze
the game this is still
still not a noisy as well as basketed
the board that's why he was world
champion and they weren't there the
bulletin there's some guy NN all right
so Bishop takes rook rook takes f1 and I
think if you show this position to a
modern strong Grandmaster they're really
going to like white and a fat this gives
me very bad memories I had a game in the
Chess Club upstairs against the Iranian
American Grandmaster L Shan more idea
body he sacrificed an exchange in
similar fashion against me to King's
Indian and they just tore me up and he
did it really quickly and honestly no
exchange sacrifice unclear and then I
just resigned like it was very similar
to this game actually he just put all
his pieces he had me and my rips
couldn't do anything although I don't
think my knight was so bad maybe it was
okay but yeah this reminds me of that
game except I got beat worse so that's
why I'm sitting here lecturing to you
and not playing for the World
Championship okay so Knight to g6
because the Knights hanging Bishop g4
where's the bishop going ecigs this
should be six now would be quite good
you don't I mean okay so black prevented
Bishop e6 by playing Knight f4 now
officially six you can take it see the
911 remove the defender with a famous
Petrosian exchange sacrifice he's only
made one this game rook takes f4 now
this gives me another memory except it's
a good memory I have some good memories
in chess I played in the Chicago open
many years ago if you're at home you can
go to the MSA for been fine gold and
look at Chicago opens there were about
10 years ago approximately and in one of
them I played vitami repitition who
earlier in his career was one of Karpov
seconds and episome was a stronger
Grandmaster than I was I was even a
grandmaster and he was much higher rated
than me and I thought he was going to
play this line in the King's Indian with
Wyatt and I thought I'd have black
against
but the pairings weren't up till the
next day this was like 2:00 in the
morning so I prepared for two hours from
2:00 to 4:00 a.m. a lion the King's
Indian for black that I thought he would
play for white and I looked the pairings
in the morning and I was paired with
that mission I was like okay good
and he went right into the line I played
my novelty I prepared I moved 20 and I
beat him when the game ended my friends
were like how did you do and they were
gonna say like I lost I said I won and
they said you won you were down two
pieces for a rook they all said it
separately and I said no I had two rooks
so they saw it it looks like two visas
for a ruck but it's two rugs so if you
looked at this position and took off the
black rook I would have two pieces for a
rock so you would assume White's winning
but that's two pieces for two works
that's not as easy okay and my opponent
basically had nothing he was just down
to visas for two rooks so I won but all
my friends were confused they very
rarely see two rooks for two pieces well
here you go through attrition pieces
okay Bishop e6 check now you can vote we
haven't voted all day even in the class
you guys didn't see at home we didn't
vote in that class either how many
illegal moves does black have let's see
if you guys are awake that's too hard
even at home they're scratching their
head confused how many possible legal
mooses black eV
what Wow
they said I'm sorry for Wow okay I count
two and two are the ones you're looking
at are illegal I have a queen on B to
see this Queen you you can't you can't
go to these squares yeah you can play
rook f7 or King f8 so I think it's two
but yeah they correct you three to four
so I was getting scared okay so what did
Spassky do King f8 or rook f7 anyone
rook f7 yeah King f8 is risky right so
we go Queen h8 check here and then there
were like three ways to win let's see I
like Queen g7 it's probably wrong but I
like it
and then while my t4 has to win Knight
f5 has to win they have to win even if
they don't but there was some variation
that was like mate wish I knew what it
was only JT Machuca knows I think
actually the computer wanted to play
Knight f5 check and then Queen h7 check
and then something like this of I guess
Bishop takes us better our queen takes
is probably better ok again this Knight
is here that's unfortunate
ok yeah I think it actually announced to
mate after King f8 but you know I'm not
good enough to know why okay so you
played rook f7 that's the safest move
and any Grandmaster would gladly trade
this rook for this bishop because that
bishops better that's a great Bishop
okay but petrosian's that interested in
winning the exchange he could promote a
pawn to a rook and sacrificed the
exchange no not really because this
Knights terrible okay so 94 getting the
knight into the game
now we got night and this was before Bob
Seger even had the music out he still
worked on his Night Moves what you think
66 Bob Seger no probably not
yeah probably probably still going to
high school were pioneer high school
okay so Queen h4 was played let's look
at the variation they get cuz it's funny
Rick a7 Knight f5 threatening Knight h6
check and threatening even better than
90 h6 check Dani but this is better
that's mate so it's better it mates
better so Queen f8 stopping me Queen f6
I hate when that happens
unless I'm white then I like it quite a
bit and and actually the game would end
in a draw here due to stalemate no no
sense of humor
no all right and whites threatening
everything but mainly nine eight six
check that g5 is okay - okay
so instead Spassky played Queen h4
counter play Knight takes D six I hate
when that happens
Queen g5 check King h1 and now if you
take the knight on e3 check Queen Shak
and Knight f5 check attacking the Queen
and that's not good now I'm not going to
lose my queen
for example if you go here I'm going to
take check and then take your queen okay
so he played the move rook a7 or as the
computer would say rook a a7 even though
they don't rock campo de 7 computers do
that when you play the nimzo-indian and
you play Knight G to e2 and your other
knight is pinned
I write 92 because the other and I can't
go to e 2 computers right now GE 2 and
they know that I can't move because they
won't let it move so I don't get it also
most people do that most grandmasters
would write a GE 2 even though the other
night
can't go to e2 I'm in the minority now
in the spice Cup about three years ago
my son Spencer had a game where he
employed the same tactic Petrosian
employed here and almost the same wow it
was pretty similar and he knew this he
knew the final of this game so he
probably didn't know the whole game but
that's a funny turn around black was
trying to attack white white sacrificed
the exchange and then white was all over
black and black who played 985 on move
8ish well that's the nice spin of the
whole game and it's sort of like Morphy
games except we don't see that nowadays
a grandmaster playing a knight to the
side it just sits there the whole game
now another pleasant memory in the in
the national open I don't know eight or
nine years ago maybe I play Dimitri
Gurevich in the last round and the
winter tied for first
and he played Knight h5 in the opening
and then his knight just stayed on h5 so
then I won because his knight was on h5
yeah and here the Knights on a5 and
there's no plan the Queen side nobody
cares about the Queen side ok the plays
all in the Kings side and active pieces
is very important not just whether their
rooks bishops or Knights and that's
something I want to talk about for hours
because I get paid by the hour
rooks are better than bishops and rooks
are better than Knights but it depends
and the endgame there's no question but
in this position if I can have these two
or these two there's also no question we
just do better they have more places to
go and they're doing more and usually in
the opening rooks are not worth very
much you don't even move them then when
you do move them they still can't do
anything and what you see quick wins by
more fee that are 10 to 20 moves long
usually they're not the rooks that are
doing it usually it's the bishops of the
Knights so Petrosian was very well known
for sacrificing the exchange or as they
call it in Europe the quality because
his minor PC
was better than the rook or that made
his position better for some other
reasons and of course any Grandmaster if
tall they could have a knight on g6 a
bishop on e6 you never get to see this
you don't get that so people aren't even
winning the exchange to let their
opponents do that so you never see these
positions and the reason we don't see
those anymore is because of games like
this and we learn and we're like Oh more
if you did that we're not doing that
with like the opponent did and then we
go to synapse and Kappa Blanc and so on
and then when we see these games and
we're like wow that dish is better than
the rook and there's a funny joke they
used to go around the US Championships
before they had them here the ones in
the 80s and they agreed all the players
agreed that minor pieces are better than
rooks because there are so many exchange
sacrifices and you'd always win okay
they were kidding but there was a lot of
exchange sacrifices where the middle
game the bishops and Knights were just
tearing the other guy up okay and the
rooks were just like defending now of
course if you ask any good player if you
want to go into an equal ending where
there's three pawns on each side and
then you have a rook and they have a
knight okay the guy with the knight
designs so an endgame rooks just crushed
knights and bishops but not both at the
same time and this position blacks rooks
are pinned and terrible and whites minor
pieces are all amazing and now White has
a winning tactic which I'm sure you all
knew before the game that was a very
famous and this was probably the main
reason Petrosian won the match this gave
him a 2 to 0 lead does anybody see what
he did here a brilliant tactical finish
the first move is and with a lot of you
would play the second move nuts so much
no ship takes f7 right Queen where Queen
where yeah right so after rook takes
Bishop quiquina a change that's what you
were thinking right yeah a world
championship too now I was playing a
Soviet player in the 80s or 90s 92 so I
guess he was Russian then and I played
Queen h8 check not this kind of position
and he could take it then I had a double
checkmate going on so I was long I play
Queen AGA against Russian grandmasters
better than me and it wins the game
right away even better than a World
Championship and it's funny
Petrosian is known as a large sort of a
boring player and have a lot of draws
and the two things he's known for in
chess are exchanged sacrifices and Queen
sacrifices because he had more than one
really brilliant Queen sacrifice there's
another one where his opponents King
walks up the board and he's like oh boy
Chuck made my opponent that's a good
idea
now this Queen sacrifice is only used to
win all of blacks pieces a mundane
reason takes check and ok White's up a
piece for nothing and in spencer's game
his opponents King was on g7 and his
Queen was out of the back rank and he
played Queen h8 and you had to take it
and get lose the same pieces and the
question is you know when did Petrossian
see Queen h8 3 moves ago four moves ago
before the game started yeah games
played today when we see such moves the
internet bullies are like this is all
home prep ok but that this wasn't a home
prep yeah but yeah very nice game from a
World Championship we were talking
before the class not you at home but
with these people and we were like who
won this match but Petrosian won twelve
and a half 11 and a half after Spassky
did so much work you know winning all
these matches beating tall handily and
then he lost the match and had to wait
three more years became the world
champion and then lost to Fischer of
course and later he played in candidates
matches for the World Championship also
probably his most famous was against
court
joy where Spassky won four games in a
row but still lost the match and chess
is hard